let's uh black Ford versus Ferrari it is
it's a terrific story and as we said
it's about this challenge these two guys
are united in this challenge to build a
Ford that can a race car an American
race car that can be the creme de la
creme right of the Italian race car
right and so it's you and Christian
Bale's character and this is these are
real people yeah you're Carroll Shelby
this amazing charismatic auto builder
and then Christian Bale's character is a
real mechanic slash racer yes exactly
who was who was very he was very
uncompromising right and he was a purist
and so he burned a lot of bridges
because he wouldn't you know he would
win every battle but he would lose the
war so as a result this guy never got
some of the great the the great rides
and he's coming to the end of his career
and but Shelby who Shelby was a great
race racer before a heart condition kind
of took him out of that and so he had
won LeMond he was the only American to
do that and he recognized in this guy
you know he said if you know this guy if
he can just get out of his own way is is
the guy who can who can win them on
again for the Americans and for Ford
Christian Bale I mean I love your yet
your portrayal in this movie and it's a
it's a Christian Bale is just such a
shapeshifter that he's a completely
different guy almost every time yeah you
see him he he really is a method actor
is easy not is he someone who really
becomes the character because oh he has
this very thick British accent in the
movie and he I don't know if that's
unusual to work with someone who's
working that way or is out some people
do in Christian is a good example of
somebody he'll stay in the voice and in
the physicality of the character for the
entire time but he's not like I've known
his wife longer than him I've known his
wife for more than 20 years and it's and
so we would have very kind of normal
conversations on set it's just that he's
speaking in that way yeah and he's in
that physicality it's not like I say hey
you know how see be doing and he goes I
don't know who that is I'm Ken miles I
don't know so annoying
no it would just mean he's crazy
you know like I've I've laughed as if
somebody asked him that we were doing an
interview together the other day and
somebody asked him that he goes it's not
he goes if that were the case when I got
in the car and drove away I just keep
going right he's like you know we get a
call sheet every day it says you have to
show up here at 7:00 in the morning and
we ought to start working is yes we know
we're making a movie it's just that's
what works for him and and and you that
guy's process is clearly working well so
you can't you know what I mean it's like
that is absolutely it's just a kind of a
practical thing for him we have a clip
here from the film which which one is
this I'm not they I know there's a few
but I didn't know which one they finally
decided to go I think it's the one where
I'm announcing that we're gonna go to
LeMond but Christians still on the fence
as to whether or not he wants to drive
so I I kind of try to bait him alright
let's take a look at this clip from Ford
versus Ferrari when I was 10 years old
pop said to me son
it's a truly lucky man who knows what he
wants to do in this world because that
man will never work a day in his life
but there are a few precious few and
he'll I don't know if they're lucky or
not but there are a few people who find
something they have to do some obsesses
them
some if they can't do it she's gonna
drive them clean out of their mind I'm
that guy and I know one other man feels
exactly the same his name his name is
mr. Henry Ford
and together we're gonna build the
fastest automobiles in the world
[Applause]